[Music]
Disney Princesses have become iconic
throughout the ages from their facial
features to their hair their looks are
pretty unique but what if their faces
and clothes were different would you
still be able to tell them apart now is
the time to see these characters as you
may have never seen them before just
wait until you see the Disney Princesses
reimagined as dinosaurs if you're new to
our channel don't forget to click the
subscribe button and give our video a
big thumbs up you're ready to be stunned
because today we are going to show you
15 Disney Princesses reimagined by
amazing artists abstract princesses this
section is dedicated to the abstract
collective of artists who have taken
unique liberties with their
reinterpretations of Disney Princesses
one artist shows just the hair outline
of several Disney Princesses dressed in
suits from Quentin Tarantino's Reservoir
Dogs this one is of dung beetles flying
atop Disney Princesses heads and this
one presents them as a series of dryer
lint take a look at this hysterical
mustache series and this wacky
inflatable whaling arms one our favorite
though is this wrestling match of
Cinderella flying through the air when
it comes to the weird and wacky of
Disney reimagining these images
definitely take the cake gender swapped
princesses princesses aren't the only
ones with distinct styles and Disney
films the gentlemen of these films have
a distinct style all their own what
would you think if it princesses and
princes swapped outfits a Japanese
digital artist created some amazing
conceptual designs depicting just that
he says he loves Disney and draws these
for fun and respect of the originals he
seeks no profit how cool are these
outfits of our favorite girls the
princess in the frogs tiana looks super
cute and navin's clothes Belle and Ariel
look very dapper and Eric and beast
clothes
Esmerelda Pocahontas and Mulan are
looking mighty fierce and ready for
battle in their outfits it looks like
these princesses can rock just about any
outfit anyway all we can say is thank
you for these creations princesses as
men so we had some fun looking at Disney
Princesses dressing in their princess
outfits and we totally loved them so
what would our favorite princesses look
like if they were men one extremely
talented artist named tsuchimi Chen
accomplished just that when she gender
swapped the Disney Princesses here is a
male version of Elsa from frozen
and we totally love this gender swapped
bell and beast beast is looking very
pretty
Pocahontas and Ariel are looking
extremely handsome and how cute are
their companions Miko and flounder the
details in color in Sookie's work are
flawless and amazing we definitely want
to see more of John's work how cool
would it be to do the film's over with
these characters real sized princesses
Disney Princesses are world renowned for
their breathtaking beauty sweeping
through the streets singing and twirling
and gowns but our Disney princesses slim
figures realistic or is it a distorted
vision of what a woman is to look like
this tumblr artist who goes by the name
the nameless doll wanted to combat the
unrealistic proportions particularly the
tiny waist lines that the Disney
Princesses have the nameless dolls
version of Belle has more realistic
proportions striking isn't it here is
frozen Zanna before and after this is
Rapunzel from tangled before and here
she is
after four years fans have called on
Disney to bring a more realistic Disney
Princess to the screen after seeing
these maybe they will take the hint
there princesses might be fuller but
gorgeous nonetheless rebel princesses
the princesses of Disney have a
reputation of being sweet and innocent
with not a mean bone in their body sure
they have sass and can throw a mean
punch
but they aren't full-fledged
troublemakers the princesses innocence
and naivety of the world tend to lead
them to fall into trouble then sometimes
end up in jail captured by evil villains
or worse almost dead
thankfully the print save Snow White
with that kiss but what would these
princesses look like if they were more
rebellious thanks to Evie art we don't
have to wonder check out gothic belle
glam Cinderella hipster Jasmine pinups
no rebellious tank and hipster Ariel
most of these princesses are
unrecognizable but that doesn't stop
them from looking good
star wars princesses with new star wars
films coming out the fandom is growing
even more we love Star Wars and we love
Disney Princesses so why not combine the
two talented artist Ralph Sibelius did
just that take a look at Jedi Ariel and
her double lightsabers Elsa as a Sith
Ice Queen and Snow White as a Sith Lord
are amazing we bet that they would rule
the galaxy except when jedi Ariel comes
around
they're Padawan Rapunzel her lightsaber
is part of her long hair how creative is
Ralf Aurora is perfect as frozen
Carbonite Han Solo she is sleeping
beauty in the most Star Wars way
possible with Star Wars now being owned
by Disney we wonder if this mashup will
ever become a reality
bearded princesses this next reimagining
series might just be the most weirdly
satisfying and unsettling of them all
illustrator Adam Ellis developed an
entire series of Disney Princesses with
plush beards they were created in honor
of Movember where men don't shave for
the entire month of November to raise
awareness for men's health Adam's images
are just as fun as the titles he has for
them such as this Disney film entitled
the bearded mermaid look at Ariel with
those flowing red locks on her chin or
princess mustache Arella talking with
her fairy godmother
Alison beard land Beauty in the beard
and beard on ttis just take a look at
Sleeping Beauty mooo long beard the
princess and the beard and beard Lantis
the lost Empire and who could forget the
all-time classic beard Ladin featuring
princess jazz beard we can tell Adam had
a lot of fun creating these presidential
princesses the princesses of Disney are
far removed from the political landscape
of the world they live in their castles
palaces and even under the sea they long
for living extravagant dreamy lives with
no desires of standing in front of a
podium they don't want to give
long-winded speeches full of never to be
filled promises for the people
however in 2016 MTV decided to bring
these two worlds crashing into one
another
MTV commissioned artist Annabel Coe to
combine her love of Disney characters
with 2016 presidential hopefuls and the
resulting portraits are wildly
hysterical Carly Fiorina is Princess
Jasmine Mike Huckabee as Tiana Jeb Bush
as Ariel and Ted Cruz as Snow White
Bernie Sanders as human Ariel Hillary
Clinton as Cinderella and Donald Trump
as grumpy sleeping beauty these images
can't be unseen but we love how
hilarious they are makeup artist gone
rogue growing up it's hard to escape
never seeing a Disney film once you've
seen one you typically fall into the
love it or leave it category this next
artist is a prime example except their
artistic interpretation exceeds the
a pencil to paper Richard Schaffer is a
22 year old freelance makeup artist who
transforms himself into princesses from
his favorite Disney movies this guy has
some serious skills I mean just look at
all these pictures Belle Pocahontas Snow
White Cinderella and Ariel the list goes
on and on Richard says dressing up has
helped him to feel more confident as a
person with over 250 followers on
Instagram it sure shows reinvented
princesses for those of you who spend
hours every day surfing to the endless
array of Instagram feeds you have
probably already come across the work of
Isabel stab she is a freelance
illustrator who blew up Instagram with
crisp reimagining of the classic Disney
Princesses she says each of these images
took her around
8 to 12 hours to recreate the ladies
fresh bold looks the entire process is
done in Corel Painter and a few last
touch-ups done with Photoshop here is
Esmeralda from The Hunchback of Notre
Dom now we know she's not technically a
princess but with this makeover she is
looking absolutely royal how about
adorable Belle with those cheeks
Jasmine's highlighting contour are
positively radiant
and how about Ariel check out those
pouty lips and shiny hair and how about
those wide blue eyes ooh what a
reimagining realistic princesses just
when you thought something reimagined
countless different ways couldn't be
reinvented anymore along comes jerk of a
tenon he is a 27 year old graphic artist
based in Melbourne Australia his
stunning interpretations created a
firestorm over the Internet he turned
our favorite Disney Princesses into real
people so if you've ever wondered what
they would look like as real-life people
this is for you
take a look at a real-life portrait of
Princess Anna complete with adorable
freckles this one of Rapunzel pulling on
her hair or Merida from brave she seems
so real with her curls down to the
freckles and wrinkles in the dress it's
easy to forget that these are not real
photographs but he doesn't just stop at
princesses take a look at Eric from The
Little Mermaid
Prince Hans and Kristoff of frozen and
adorable Prince Naveen if only they were
real huh
mommy princesses after our favorite
princesses got their happily ever afters
we wish we could still see more of their
lives what happens when their dreams
come true do they start families one
artist takes us through the journey of
motherhood with our favorite princesses
artist Kristen Reeves was inspired to
reimagine her favorite Disney Princesses
as mothers when she was pregnant with
her own son
check out Belle's sweet embrace with her
sweet baby Ariel looks so happy holding
her tiny daughter Jasmine's adorable
baby looks quite content being in her
arms how adorable are the pigtails on
Rapunzel's daughter we love these sweet
moments of motherhood the soft more
subdued colors are totally working for
these tender moments it looks like
motherhood suits these princesses very
well we also love to see that our
princesses have equally adorable babies
the loss of princesses with the release
of the new Jurassic world film our love
of dinosaurs has been respect our
favorite dinosaurs in the film the
velociraptors artist Laura Cooper
decided that she would commemorate the
release of Jurassic world by reimagining
princesses as Raptors she says that a
princess is many things and a raptor is
one of them she took this concept
literally and gave us this series of
hysterical raptors look at Anna and Elsa
Raptors
we love the Merida Raptor whose face is
covered with red curly hair Belle Raptor
still looks lovely in her yellow ball
gown as does Tiana Raptor and how about
Raptor Pocahontas and that flowing hair
these Raptors are not only clever but
also hilarious
we hope Laura continues making all
future Disney characters into hungry
raptors rock princesses through the ages
of Disney films princesses have played a
part in every child development growing
up one way or another there really is no
escaping the vortex which is Walt Disney
for this very reason a lot of people in
the world actually despise princesses
they feel princesses are bad role models
and contain no substance as they're
usually trapped by the bad guy this
concept of no substance was taken quite
literally by artist Kevin bulk he
created a series of princesses as rocks
you were that right rocks he took one of
the most recognizable features of these
princesses their hair and put it on top
of rocks we can still recognize them
just by their signature look
this concept is hysterical as it is
ironic clever
Kevon clever punk-rock princesses disney
princesses are known for being songbirds
as well as being beautiful but what
would happen if we gave our favorite
princesses a taste of some punk rock and
heavy metal music what would their songs
sound like what would they look like a
couple of artists have reimagined the
princesses as princesses of hunk rock
and metal check out Ariel's bright pink
hair dark makeup and tattoos
we are totally jealous of bells awesome
two-toned blue hair how cute is Rapunzel
look with her long pink hair the dark
makeup and long lashes around Ana's eyes
make them look even bigger this
reimagining is a huge departure from the
usual Disney princess but it is so much
fun to see we aren't too sure Disney is
quite ready for some heavy-metal ballads
just yet which one of these creative
reimagined princesses was your favorite
why let us know in the comments section
below
if you'd like to see more awesome videos
like this one don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]